c'est quasiment certain on aura
plusieurs vaccins avec des techniques
différentes et c'est à dire
vraisemblablement d efficacité
différentes
[Musique]
on ne va pas les écureuils je suis
biologiste et l'immunologiste et je suis
maître de recherche au fonds national de
la recherche scientifique belge
d'après launay cilic 300 vaccins
différents qui sont actuellement en
développement à différents stades donc
candidat vaccin est donc parmi ces 300
vaccins
toujours selon l' oms ça devient très
difficile à soutenir
il y en aurait moins de 30 qui seraient
en cours d'évaluation dans des essais
cliniques chez l'homme et 10 serait en
phase iii des essais cliniques qui est
la dernière phase d'évaluation avant
validation est donc actuellement des
homologations le camp chine et en russie
[Musique]
donc les études cliniques de phase 1
vise à vérifier sur un très petit nombre
d'individus
si on n'a pas de réaction toxique
évidente est rapide et les études
cliniques de phase ii vise à vérifier si
ces vaccins à guise bien une réponse
immunitaire des marqueurs de réponse
militaire comme la production
d'anticorps
en principe c'est l'étude de phase iii
sur un très large nombre d'individus
plusieurs milliers qui permet de mesurer
la protection réelle sur le terrain
conférée par le vaccin
les résultats préliminaires de l'étude
de phase iii du vaccin tigers une très
très encourageant
c'est enthousiasmant il faut quand même
la relativiser dans le sens où elle
survient à un moment les participants à
l'étude viennent de recevoir la deuxième
injection du vaccin donc à ce stade par
exemple il est impossible de savoir
combien de temps le vaccin peut protéger
on ne peut pas non plus évaluer la
manière dont le niveau de protection va
évoluer le temps et on ne sait pas non
plus s'il vaccin protège depuis que les
catégories à risque
en fait c'est un vaccin qui activent le
système immunitaire au moyen d'un raid
messager dont la séquence là codé pour
une protéine virale
l'agent pathogène contre lequel on peut
accéder
donc la rn codant pour cet antigène est
enrobé dans une membrane lipidique
il est administré en intramusculaire aux
patients et donc ce sont les cellules du
patient qui vont produire la protéine
virale qui a duré la réponse immunitaire
donc on injecte pas de virus vivants ni
date du vent mais c'est une technologie
qui reste un entraîneur dans le sens où
elle n'a pas été utilisé pour un vaccin
actuellement sur le marché
donc on n'a pas de recul par rapport à
cette technologie est elle présente une
série davantage notamment l' avantage de
permettre une production très rapide de
grandes quantités de vaccins pour le
vaccin a littéralement synthétiser il
nécessite pas de phases la culture par
exemple du virus
par contre il a aussi des inconvénients
exemple le fait d'être conservée à très
basse température moins 70 degrés
centigrades
parce que la graine est très fragile
donc son stockage et son utilisation à
large échelle nécessite des
infrastructures particulière
concrètement dans cette étude clinique
de phase iii
il ya eu plus de quarante trois mille
participants ont été enrôlées et donc la
moitié ont reçu le vaccin et l'autre
moitié ou reçu un placebo en deux
injections et donc à ce stade de l'étude
les auteurs ont observé 93 chalco vide
dans l'ensemble des sujets donc à la
fois ceux qui ont eu le vaccin et ceux
qui ont lu le placebo et donc on a neuf
personnes vaccinées qui ont développé le
vide et 84 personnes ayant reçu le
placebo qu'ils ont développée donc le
chiffre de 90 % signifie que les
personnes vaccinées on était dix fois
moins nombreuses que ceux ayant eu
placebo a contracté le comique 19
les vaccins chinois le sinovac le silo
forme donc ça ce sont des vaccins qui
sont d'inactiver donc l'agent pathogène
virus et cultivé ensuite on you tube et
c'est ce virus inactivé qui sert
lui-même de vaccins donc c'est une
technologie qui est très ancienne était
déjà utilisé du 20e siècle par exemple
pour le premier vaccin contre la polio
alors ces vaccins n'ont pas encore été
homologuée mais la chine a déjà proposé
d utiliser pour des vaccinations
d'urgence pour le vaccin russes
s'appellent spoutnik 5
c'est un vaccin qui est directeur virale
nous réplicable donc un directeur qui
est capable d'infecter nos cellules
mais qui en principe ne cause aucun
désagrément et ce type de stratégie par
contre a déjà été utilisé plusieurs fois
pour des vaccins humains qui ont bien
fonctionné mais un certain recul par
rapport à cette technologie ne dispose
pas encore l'heure actuelle des données
de l'étude de phase iii donc c'est une
efficacité qui est plus espérer que
démontrer d'entre eux quatre ces vaccins
le temps moyen pour développer et
autoriser un vaccin est en moyenne de 7
ans traditionnellement mais on n'a
jamais jusqu'à présent dans l'histoire
de la médecine moderne qu'un mise sur le
marché un vaccin qui n'avait été testé
que six mois entre guillemets en phase 3
il est admirable
si on évalue un vaccin que pendant six
mois il est impossible de prédire
combien de temps ce vaccin sera
protecteur et il est également
impossible d'exclure qu'ils aient des
effets négatifs à long terme le
principal risque en fait c'est que même
si on exclut je dirais les gros accident
de vaccination si les vaccins a mis sur
le marché à venir elles satisfont pas le
public en termes de protection en termes
d'efficacité on risque d'augmenter cette
méditation vaccinale je pense que c'est
ce qui fait le plus peur aux
scientifiques à l'heure actuelle on sait
très bien que cette hésitation vaccinale
est déjà très très haut dans certains
pays comme la france ou la plus de 60%
des hésitants en matière de vaccination
donc ce serait un graal entre guillemets
6,6 en allant trop vite on en arrivait à
autoriser des vaccins qui ne soit pas
efficace qui éventuellement et certains
effets secondaires
on pourrait augmenter les hésitations
vaccinale est donc on pourrait pourrir
les campagnes de vaccination pour toute
une série d'agents pathogènes pour autre
que le public 19 pour lequel on a
pourtant des vaccins qui sont efficaces
et absolument sans danger
le développement d'un vaccin peut être
vue comme la solution ultime pour ce
type de pandémie
je pense qu'il faut relativiser le
concept même de vaccins
ici ce qu'a montré la pandémie que 8,19
c'est que notre capacité de réponse à ce
type de pandémie elle est finalement
relativement calme on ne dispose pas
d'un vaccin a par définition contraint
agents pathogènes émergents ne dispose
pas non plus généralement d'un
traitement spécifique efficace pour
finalement tout ce qu'on a pour lutter
contre un agent pathogène émergents ont
les vieilles stratégies entre mm
quarantaine de distanciation social en
est finalement très démuni dans une
réflexion beaucoup plus large qui serait
intéressant c'est plutôt de développer
les stratégies d'anticipation et des
stratégies de prévention
ça ce sont sans doute les stratégies qui
seraient les plus efficaces et à terme
les moins coûteuses pour lutter contre
ces bandes
[Musique]